c'est nos monts sutton la voie de la
société mais oui déjà
par l'entremise du procureur général de
la république des prothèses
[Musique]
et pas le faire on règle
monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les jurés gauchistes curie
j'étais encore un petit garçon en 1960
c'était déjà un vieux cochon en 1960
quand j'ai découvert le mensuel hara
kiri
je pense est d'ailleurs l'un des plus
vieux fidèle de cette exécrable torchon
puisque ma soeur non lip ali le pèlerin
quelqu'un puisse que je possède à peu
près tous les exemplaires depuis 20 ans
en 1960 ce n'était pas tout à fait le
même journal qu'aujourd'hui ils étaient
disons plus plus élégants dans l'ue
révérence plus distingués dans le
subversif plus sophistiqués dans ce cas
théologique
en un mot il était plus raffiné et pour
plusieurs raisons la première c'est que
françois cavanna dans les années 60
n'était pas encore décoré comme il est
aujourd'hui il ne rêvait pas encore
depuis qu'il fauteuil de maurice
genevoix l'académie française et il
n'allait pas encore à toutes les
premières d opérette de francis lopez
vous me direz monsieur président est
bien courageux de ma part d'agresser
qu'evan a alors qu'il n'est pas là
certes non mais vous avez vu ses épaules
et d'autre part lui-même encourage la
lâcheté à longueur de page donc je vais
pas me gêner
je disais donc en 1960
françois cavanna était déjà italien
certes mais pas au point de se prendre
pour le pape
alors qu'aujourd'hui à longueur de
colonnes dans le cercle l'osservatore
romano dans le dans charlie hebdo
pardon il distribue bénédiction ou une
malédiction avec la tranquille assurance
est la parfaite sérénité que lui confère
l'infaillibilité papale lors d'un
inoubliable grand échiquier qui était
consacré à kavanagh jack chance elle
avait longuement hésité ils se
demandaient si monseigneur martin aurait
pas fait un meilleur invité mais il faut
bien que toutes les tendances de
l'église s'exprime à la télévision tour
à tour un jour kavanagh un jour
monseigneur lefebvre un jour marty et
c'est l'ordre cet inoubliable grand
échiquier les vieux lecteur de rats qui
rit de l'hebdo comme moi en sont restées
sur le cul on nous a fait assister à une
séance de travail rue des trois portes
l'adresse actuelle des éditions du
square on se serait cru
une conférence du figaro monsieur le
président en mon âme et conscience
mesdames et messieurs les jurés
je ne pense pas que les journalistes de
monsieur robert hersant puisse être
aussi aimable avec leurs patrons que ce
d'hara kiri l'était ce soir là avec leur
papa
pour en finir avec les années 60 hara
kiri
je citerai quatre noms quatre noms qui
figuraient au générique d'hara kiri jean
christophe averty topor romain bouteille
fred si comme moi vous pensez que le
point commun entre ces quatre
personnages c'est en plus du talent un
certain goût pour leur propre
indépendance d'esprit
vous comprendrez pourquoi ils ont quitté
la maison mère est pourquoi je m'étonne
que cabu l'ait pas fait en 66 frais des
parties d'hara kiri en emportant avec
lui son âme ses roulottes ces sombres
bohémiens sa folie métaphysique et son
nom son encre de chine
il est allé se promener partout et
notamment au journal pilote dans les
collaborateurs sont de plus en plus
brillants au fur et à mesure que le
temps passe et dire qu'il nous arrive et
dit de vous y commettre es mémoire
pilote en vente partout dit france et
pas d'apéritif à part c'est pas la
publicité c'est une réflexion désabusée
sur le coût du papier c'est vrai donc je
viens de le démontrer avec éclat frais
des coupables
il ne nous reste plus qu'à trouver de
quoi il est coupable de désertion nous
dit le dossier du ministère public
personnellement la désertion des civils
en temps de paix me gêne beaucoup moins
que le nom désertion des militaires en
temps de guerre
d'ailleurs à ce propos monsieur le
président je vous fais une lettre que
vous lirez peut-être une erreur recevoir
vos papiers militaires pour partir à la
guerre exactement vers tradition mais
vous aurez jamais le temps de me
répondre avec tous ses pinces fesses qui
nous accapare il serait peut-être plus
simple d'accuser fred de folie
mégalomane en effet mesdames et
messieurs les jurés l'accusée a déclaré
dans une interview récente qu'il
aimerait bien être dieu x à mékhé mieux
reduce dieu non mais je vous le demande
mais c'est le président dieu est ce que
c'est vraiment un bon exemple pour les
chrétiens certes dieu et pas mal
toujours à leur propre sur lui comme on
le remarque et tout à l'heure d'accord
d'autre part dans son infinie bonté il
sait distribuer équitablement ses
divines largesses le caviar à neuilly
les racines aux ougandais
tout ça fonctionne très bien et nous
disons bravo dieu c'est super mais si
dieu est vraiment bon pourquoi y at il
toutes ces guerres
pourquoi l'humanité s'entre déchirent
tél pourquoi le monde est il sans cesse
à feu et à sang
pourquoi l'apocalypse nucléaire
insupportable épée de damoclès menace
tel jour et nuit
pourquoi la mort est elle toujours au
bout du chemin pourquoi l'homme est il
mauvais pourquoi les soins dont les
soins dentaires ne sont ils pas
remboursés à 100% et pourquoi neige
toujours pas la légion d'honneur à
propos d' apocalypse nucléaire
je signale à la cour que nous pouvons
voir ce soir à 20h30 sur tf1 une
émission de paul-marie de la gorce
intitulé les forces nucléaires
françaises
au cours de cette sympathique promenade
chez les vieux militaires qui sont payés
au mois pour déclencher la fin du monde
un de ces quatre
notre toujours jeune président de la
république nous dira comment il a pu ré
sur le petit bouton rouge si au soir du
grand soir on arrivait à le joindre au
téléphone je signale aux russes qu'ils
auraient intérêt à déclencher
l'apocalypse
un soir entre 6 et 8 il ya jamais de
totaliser une tonalité avec élise et ça
c'est bon il ya tant qu'eglise équipes
obtenaient les noms mais a enlevé élise
et balzac à d'autres séries tu peux pas
moi je ferais rien bombe en restant là
détail amusant au cours de cette
émission de ce soir nous nous verrons
que ce n'est pas un petit bouton rouge
qui provoque le déclenchement de la
bombe h c'est une petite clé verte a vu
ça rigole tout le temps d'une émission
les c'est vrai mais tu meures à ce soir
ben vous voyez le imaginons le dialogue
finale allô monsieur le président mes
respects monsieur le président si le
général sus mes preuves les russes
viennent de la chaîne fox le président
voulait vous déclenchez la force de
frappe s'il vous plaît eh bien écoutez
c'est une excellente question je te
remercie de me l'avoir posée au maire
mes clés à l'école
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous êtes coupable de vous prendre pour
dieu
je suggère qu'on vous crucifix si
possible trois jours avant pâques
ça vous donne une chance de vous voir
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est non non